[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
y ya está conmigo en el estudio lista
daniela blandón dan y comenzamos una
nueva semana aquí en nuestro programa y
vamos a analizar las propuestas
económicas del presidente en mayor
macrón quien ganó el día de ayer estaba
a segunda vuelta de las presidenciales
para unos cinco años más de mandato así
es a raúl muy buen inicio de semana y
frío inicio de frío inicio de semana
seguimos con el frío y la lluvia aquí el
invierno incluso sí señor pues mire este
es un tema que no es ajeno de manuel
marcaron por supuesto porque recordemos
que el presidente de francia es
economista y además fue banquero y uno
de sus principales pilares es la defensa
de lo que ha llamado el pleno empleo a
donde dice que va a llegar cuando la
tasa de desocupación sea del 5 por
ciento o menos hoy es del 7,4 por ciento
que es la cifra más baja en 15 años sin
embargo más allá del empleo los
franceses tienen varias preocupaciones
raúl una encuesta reciente de ipsos
señala que al 65 por ciento de los
ciudadanos les inquietan los precios de
la energía principalmente en este
momento de tan coyuntural más de la
mitad también se ha mostrado en zozobra
por la alta inflación
dice estar preocupado por las pensiones
y los impuestos la salud y la inequidad
social son también motivo de angustia
para los ciudadanos así es danny y el
poder adquisitivo también fue uno de los
centros de la campaña de esta reelección
de macrón claro recuerde usted que en el
debate la primera pregunta fue sobre el
tema de poder adquisitivo pues entre las
propuestas de macrón está por ejemplo
aumentar el salario de los docentes en
un 10% y reducir impuestos a través de
un paquete fiscal calculado en 15 mil
millones de euros
enmanuel macrón quiere además que las
empresas puedan dar a los empleados una
bonificación sin pagar impuestos de
hasta seis mil euros hoy esa exención
aplica para bonos de hasta dos mil euros
como presidente recordemos macrón ha
gastado miles de millones de euros para
limitar los aumentos en las facturas de
energía que son la principal
preocupación como veíamos ahora mismo
debido al inmenso repunte que han
sufrido por cuenta de la guerra ahora
veamos raúl si le parece algunas
reacciones sobre ese tema económico de
una vez
me gustaría ver más inversión en
educación y en nuevos métodos para
capacitar a los jóvenes para responder a
los problemas climáticos y creo que
estos son temas que ni siquiera se han
abordado por lo que la lucha continua el
archivo en este momento y demasiadas
divisiones tengo la impresión de que
están los ricos de un lado los pobres
del otro y la gente normal que no sabe
muy bien a dónde ir entonces tiene que
haber una cohesión con relación a eso y
sobre todo una solidaridad
es cierto que macro no habla de los
estudiantes y de lo que planea hacer por
ellos y eso es una pena estoy esperando
a ver qué piensa hacer para facilitarnos
a la vida cotidiana porque
financieramente es bastante difícil para
nosotros nos recibimos mucho apoyo así
que tendremos que ver eso pero es que
danny la propuesta económica más
polémica fue lo del aumento en la edad
de las pensiones que puso con esto y se
mantiene en esa en esa posición ya lo
veremos mccrone quiere subir
progresivamente la edad de jubilación de
62 a 65 años y aumentar también la
pensión mínima mensual a 1100 euros
durante la campaña analicemos mientras
que su contrincante había propuesto
mantener esta edad e inclusive reducir
los 60 años en casos de personas que
comenzarán a cotizar antes de los 20
años macrón siempre le cuestionó a
manning lepén que fiscalmente eso era
imposible justamente este lunes su
ministro de finanzas- bruno le maire
dijo que la propuesta se va a mantener
pero que hay voluntad de discutir
ciertos aspectos como este cuánto podrán
jubilarse los que empiezan a trabajar
antes de los 20 años es decir si van a
tener que esperar también hasta los 65
años no puede haber una reducción en esa
edad claro y también hay propuestas
sobre cambio climático sobre ese tema
que digo macrón claro aunque más con un
censo sido desde un principio con el
eslogan hacer que el planeta vuelva a
ser grande sus credenciales ecológicas
son mixtas por un lado recordemos que
presionado por las multitudinarias
protestas de los llamados chalecos
amarillos macro en suspendió un aumento
que tenía previsto del impuesto al
combustible pero por el otro lado el
macrón ecologista en campaña se
comprometió a construir 6 reactores
nucleares de nuevas
también desarrollar la energía solar así
como los parques eólicos en el mar a
medida que persigue esta meta de
volverse neutral en carbono para 2050
también prometió más transporte público
en todo el país esto para alejar a las
personas de la dependencia de los
automóviles desgracias entonces por toda
la información económica nos vemos más
adelante con más economía en directo
américa